tom hardy woody harrelson and the
greatest symbiote clash of the century
is coming after the first venom film
we're all eagerly awaiting the
supposedly even more impressive
villainous sequel here's everything we
know about venom let there be carnage
while marvel studios may reign supreme
as the top dog in the comic book movie
world it's hardly the only studio
bringing some of marvel comics biggest
names to the silver screen for decades
sony pictures has brought fan favorite
spider-man to the movies through both
live action and animation the studio has
rung so much mileage out of the
character that it's already seen him go
through three iterations beginning with
toby mcguire restarting with andrew
garfield and ending with tom holland but
the valuable spider-man ip doesn't just
include any and every conceivable form
of spidey himself including apparently a
spider pig it also includes all the
ancillary and related characters
connected to marvel's classic spidey
stories that were rolled into the
original sony licensing deal taking a
page out of the mcu's book sony's begun
expanding its franchise to include films
that actually focus on secondary
characters even villains in the
spider-man canon that means one villain
first and foremost venom all due respect
to the green goblin venom got his first
solo film in 2018 to the delight of
comic book fans everywhere venom opened
to theaters on october 5th 2018
introducing the world to tom hardy's
interpretation of eddie brock the host
body of the titular symbiote the film's
release marked the first cinematic
depiction of the iconic toothy villain
since teen idol topher grace first gave
the character life in spider-man 3. over
the course of the venom movie's
theatrical run it raked in roughly
856.1 million dollars at the box office
more than making back its budget of
somewhere between 110 to 116 million
dollars although it wasn't necessarily a
home run with critics casual moviegoers
seem to enjoy it considering the largely
positive fan response and impressive
financials sony green led to sequel in
no time entitled venom let there be
carnage
like many other recent films the
pandemic has played a part in venom let
there be carnage's delayed release date
with andy circus at the helm the film
was planned to hit the big screen on
october 2nd 2020 which obviously never
came to pass sony moved the date to june
25th 2021 and then again to september
24th 2021 sony pictures entertainment
chairman tony vitziquera told radio
times what we won't do is make the
mistake of putting a very very expensive
200 million dollar movie out in the
market unless we're sure that theaters
are open and operating at significant
capacity fortunately with the u.s
starting to return to normal and emerge
from the troubles of the pandemic the
sequel should stick with its latest
state so when will this movie be
released well as we make this video it's
slated for october 15 2021 but let's be
honest is that gonna change likely just
keep checking looper and we'll let you
know when it comes out
most audiences will pay to see marvel's
anti-hero venom brought back to the big
screen no matter what but fortunately
with this film they'll also get the
chance to check out an impressive
assortment of actors doing what they do
best at the same time as far as
returning cast members go tom hardy is
coming back as eddie brock with his
alien parasite in tow because honestly
who else could embody this character at
this point
interestingly hardy also earns his first
story by credit on let there be carnage
it's a worthy nod to his immeasurable
contributions to shaping the character
and the script during the long
development cycle brock's ex-fiance and
weiang will once again come to life
thanks to the acting talents of michelle
williams reid scott is also set to
reprise his role as her current flame
dan lewis the big news of course is
woody harrelson's return as the
psychotic cletus cassidy whom he
portrayed in the post-credits sequence
of 2018's venom this time around he'll
finally come into his own when he is
bonded with the murderous red and black
symbiote carnage early looks at cassidy
and his alien parasite reveal a haralson
completely in his element and ready to
bring a new dynamism to the franchise
alongside harrelson rumors are swirling
that franchise newcomer naomi harris
will play another marvel villain named
shriek who will likely double as
cassidy's love interest steven graham
and sean delaney will also appear but
the nature of their roles remains
unknown plot specifics for venom let
there be carnage are still rather vague
but a few smaller ideas are floating
around at the moment it's pretty much a
given that this movie will focus heavily
on eddie and venom's dynamic as they
continue adjusting to living together as
one integrated human parasite combo deal
as producer matt tolmak told cinema
blend the heart of venom was always the
relationship between eddie and venom
these two characters these two sides
that had to figure out how to live
together and that were somehow better
together than they were separately or
more successful and what that meant one
can only hope that the two of them will
be on the same page and let there be
carnage because as the title suggests a
showdown against carnage is all but a
certainty
there's gonna be carnage
with the added dimension of shriek
reportedly planting herself firmly in
cassidy's camp this sequel could spell
bad news for brock and his parasitic
friend it's also worth noting that with
sony's decision to move forward with the
jared leto morbius solo film there could
be space to tie the venom continuity
into an even bigger cinematic hole
will venom be a part of the mcu at this
point no he will not but the confusion
is understandable the wide world of
cinema based on classic marvel comics
characters used to be somewhat
straightforward before marvel studios
was even really a thing marvel comics
offloaded the film and tv rights to some
of its individual properties to a couple
of different buyers 20th century fox
gobbled up the x-men an obvious prestige
piece of the marvel cannon it's also the
reason disney had to build phase 1 of
their mcu around the avengers instead of
the more popular mutants in this same
era of high-risk comics ventures sony
pictures got a hold of spider-man and
many related characters and story
elements interestingly the success of
fox's x-men films and sony's original
spider-man trilogy was clearly the
business predicate for the creation of
marvel studios in the mcu fast forward
to 2021 and disney has now reacquired
the x-men by way of its expensive
acquisition of 20th century fox the
spider-man character has found his way
back into the mcu as well but only with
the permission and substantial profit
participation of continuing rights
holder sony pictures the tom holland
spider-man is the result of a special
business arrangement between sony
pictures and disney it does not
officially transfer the characters
rights back to the latter nor does it
have any meaningful creative or
intellectual property impact on
ancillary characters like venom the
film's venom venom let there be carnage
spider-man into the spider-verse and the
upcoming morbius all exist in the sony
pictures spider-verse these properties
are at least in theory loosely bound to
each other but they don't have anything
to do with marvel's phase 4 wanda's
sitcom hex or the drastic ending of loki
fans were quick to dissect the brief
video looking for any and every possible
clue about the future of hardy's venom
and harrelson's carnage the first few
seconds of the trailer are pure hearty
we see eddie alone in the kitchen fixing
up a little breakfast for himself
meanwhile his body shoots out reckless
black appendages that are at least
ostensibly trying to help a hand-drawn
sign on the exposed brick wall of his
apartment reads rules no eating people
which seems like a pretty reasonable
rule to have in some ways these scenes
reveal an eddie brock more at ease with
his bodily companion than he was in the
first film though there are certainly
still some adjustments that need to be
made at least the two roommates are
feeding together and not on human heads
i have absolutely no problem with you
sticking around but if you do gonna have
to have some ground rules all right
you cannot just go around eating anybody
that you want to later in the trailer we
get our first good look at the return of
woody harrelson as cletus cassidy still
imprisoned and awaiting his execution
for all of his previous dirty dealings
the trailer actually shows us a grim
clip of cassidy entering the execution
booth the executioner sets him up for
lethal injection the needle slips in his
vein and the deadly drug cocktail starts
to pump it's at this moment that the
carnage organism awakens inside cassidy
trashing the execution booth and putting
an end to the proceedings the rest of
the trailer is all fast cuts and
percussive action in other words exactly
what you'd expect from a venom sequel
it's good to know that let there be
carnage appears to have carried over its
predecessor's black sense of humor at
least more trailers may be forthcoming
as the september 24th release date
approaches so stay tuned for any
additional peaks before the whole
feature at last descends upon the
spider-verse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the spider-verse are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one